Còn hai quay khóc, đêm vụ cầu ngon sức, hai ăn kém, kéo kia ra đình điều ló lắng,
các mẹ đang phải loại phai trước tiền hiệu SOS từ con,
lựa rằng có biết điều này không?
Các mẹ hồ như đã biết, em ngô, giữa, ngồi bài ở đây,
từ nghiên, mình li biết khó nãy là những cái quyết sị tà và thân bệnh ác viết.
Trong sự mẹ có mùi cái hợp chất mà,
ít người biết đến cái hợp chất đó chính là mêu,
mì biết còn bài khóc chất này chính là,
có khóc chất mẹ cũng có chăm sự mẹ như ngu rúc.
Bảo vệ như mặt vật,
đăng ngờ khóc chất dân tệ có hạ mà còn giúp môi giữ hệ vì sinh được vật.
Từ chi sẽ của các bất sĩ và chuyên gia dình dưỡng,
khỏi mẹ từ bắt tới năm đà dầu,
để lần sống xa lụng mươi li biết con,
bệnh có trong vì xóbrough.
Nhờ giữ chất này,
mà giúp mẹ hấp tụ tốt hơn,
ăn ngon, ngon, khiến mỗi ngày của mẹ cũng nhẹ nhàng gần hành.
Sự bắt chuyện hiện tại của con chính là nhiều buồn thị thường hoàn trước hệ.
Các mẹ ơi, cùng nhập hội xanh miêu li biết con bệnh ngẹ.